what's going on guys new Ghostbusters
trailer just hit the Internet the old
trailer the most downvoted and hated
trailer in youtube history why is that
why is there a dust storm of eight
surrounding this film well we're gonna
talk about that very subject today in a
new segment we call just take a breath
and we're gonna talk about it with a
couple of our old pals first he is the
movie fights champion and the host of
the new screen junkies plus show summer
movie report Dan Merle and he is one of
the writers of honest trailers and he
has got an awesome wrestling parody book
out called leg drop from Devastator pres
Joestar let's talk about the first
trailer for a second why and your
estimations did it get such a poor
reaction it was I mean it was a pretty
lowest-common-denominator trailer a
mediocre yeah I think it felt like
everyone's worst fear of this movie it
felt kind of blardy for a better script
darting around I think for everybody
looking for a reason to really attack
this movie because I feel like they were
there's a lot of people from a lot of
different camps which we'll talk about
yeah just waiting to pounce and I think
that trailer gave you the opportunity to
do that
I think that Paul feeds movies in
general I don't know war trailers you
know that bridesmaids and spy both in
particular didn't have trailers that
made me jump out of my seat say and that
looks like a hilarious movie and they
all turned out to be really funny but I
think the main thing that we're trying
to figure out and like I think the big
driving question of this is that with
Point Break and all these other remakes
there was so everyone said like oh that
looks terrible and with this particular
movie for a number of reasons people are
saying that oh that looks terrible
they're saying like this movie sucks
it's awful it's a piece of garbage it's
an abomination and no one's seen and
that is premature talk it is yeah you
can certainly take impressions from
trailer obviously what you're a saguaro
I had a very strong reaction to the
trailer for Jurassic OH but the
difference is I don't like this in the
trailer this is what but I still said I
can't wait to go see it and form my own
opinion could this movie just crash and
burn and be terrible sure that's in the
realm of possibility absolutely but
could it be good yeah I wish I could
just jump into a parallel
universe and let's say you put out the
same exact Ghostbusters trailer with
Channing Tatum Jonah Hill Ben Stiller
Ben Stiller let's say and then let's
have it our and Kevin Hart yeah exactly
that's a yeah but not the same trailer
with those same jokes yes I don't think
that would be the most disliked trailer
in this room YouTube no there are so
many examples of bad trailers being good
movies and good trailers being bad
movies uh uh one that wasn't a mess but
really left me flat was based on the
trailer I was so excited for the movie
pineapple Express
it had that mi a song and it looked
amazing and then that movie really just
kind of fell flat for me I love high
decibel - I could disagree with you on
that but again I I i disagree
wholeheartedly where do you stand on
pineapples but no this is a good way to
turn it's on his head yeah based on the
trailer what's happening now with
ghostbusters would be like Jo seeing the
trailer for pineapple Express and then
going on the internet and saying
pineapple Express is one of the best
comedies I've ever seen in my life
that movie is amazing if you don't know
that yeah the trailer a lot of
interesting points I want to bottom-line
it why do each of you think this movie
is getting so much hate and then
piggyback that question with what would
you say to people who are just writing
it off well I think on one hand you you
have people who feel a lot of ownership
of this franchise you know even in just
that that cinemassacre video were the
reviewer stated he's never going to
watch this movie in that video he goes
on to describe beat for be almost
exactly what this movie should have been
and so you have people who are like this
isn't what I've been imagining to be for
20 years so I'm done yeah the nostalgia
yeah the lore that's part so that's part
of it what else it would be naive to not
acknowledge that there is an
undercurrent of sexism on the part of
some people that dislike not all some
people that dislike this movie would be
naive to not think that that is one
element but too many people put all
their eggs in that basket yeah and as I
was saying um just the the nostalgia
camp that is a that's a valid point you
know i tweeted about this yesterday
there's a video came out you know like
you were saying from guys that
never gonna see and I said I think
that's really unfair and closed-minded
and a lot of people said like well I
don't you think that people have the
right to choose what they want to see in
a theater course you okay or she's like
but but but to say this I'm not gonna go
see this movie because it's terrible
that's what's not fair because you
haven't seen the movie and you're not
gonna give that movie a chance don't do
the book report when you've only read
the back cover right yeah yeah and then
I think that there is a bit of franchise
fatigue I think people are sick in
general of the repurposing of old
franchises good or bad studio films
indie films dramas they're they're going
by the wayside there that's that's the
plan now in it and it's exhausting and
when it comes out and people are
probably gonna come to me and Joe you
know on Twitter I'm sure they well after
today's episode but after the movie
comes out they're gonna come I'm just
like so you don't you feel like idiots
because you still you stuck up for the
new Ghostbusters movie know if it's a
terrible movie I won't feel bad at all
for what I said here today because I
think that every movie I don't care what
movie it is it deserves your you know it
deserves a shot innocent until proven
guilty yes exactly I believe every movie
is good until proven bad I think you
could even call us heroes both of us um
that's a step too far uh but guys who
you gonna call Ghostbusters there you go
um are you excited for this film are you
dead set against it we want to know let
us know in the comments section below
and tell us why I want to know where
you're coming from
dudes thank you for coming in and speak
in your mind yes Stan Merle I look
forward to all of the initials that you
will be calling all both of us on
Twitter okay Joe star looking forward to
talking to some Twitter eggs today I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter thanks
for watching bye bye likely prompting a
new wave of r-rated superhero films
so when Aquaman starts throwing out
sperm whale jokes you know who to thank
holy crap Deadpool no it's Rhythm Nation
era Janet Jackson yeah a
Deadpool Wow
you're showing up in your own honest
trailer that is so meta well it's kind
of my thing